thank you very much for making this your
last stop of the day before the
lightning talks I'm Allison Stanton my
pronouns are she her hers and as has
been stated my talk today is titled what
data analyst which application
developers new so can you give me a
quick show of hands who in the room here
is an application developer okay and who
here performs data analysis whether it's
in their job title or not okay who does
not do any application development and
no data analysis okay cool this is a
practical talk specifically it's centers
business practicalities is the most
important and talks about technical
practicalities to empower a business it
comes from the perspective of people
because quite honestly technology is
easy you get multiple tries you can
write and run test Suites and you get
error messages and stack traces humans
don't come with those things if you have
enough time money you can make some code
do phenomenal things it's the people
that are hard people make mistakes
people think they are so smart they
couldn't possibly have bad assumptions
and they couldn't possibly make a typo
this particular talk is going to address
the mistake application developer folk
make and how they can do better in order
to hope help the data folk it's probably
gonna sound like I'm coming down hard on
bebs but I've been a dev I am it Dev
I've been a data analyst and I've been
the boss of individuals in both of those
roles and this is the talk that I would
give to anyone who does not have the
pleasure of having me as a boss so
before I started I'm going to go through
some foundational concepts and then take
you into a series of scenarios and one
is reconciliation it's really great to
come up with a result but if it doesn't
match reality if it doesn't match other
results then you have a problem and
hopefully as data analysts you've
experienced this particular thing that
you have to do pretty much all the time
right this concept of having two sets of
numbers and making sure you understand
what the differences are making sure
that they represent what you think they
represent what is in the number what is
not on the number the other thing is
that developers are upstream of data
folks developers the ones that put
together the constraints for what we get
as data people so they're pretty
important to making sure that we get
what we need to do our job in fact you
know as I grow as a person I spend more
and more of my time closer and closer to
the front of projects to make sure that
everything is set up correctly so that I
or someone is working for me can for
sure get to what they they need to get
and they can't do that if the data isn't
in the right place and saved in the
right way and you have the right feels
and all of those good things so these
are frictional scenarios I've mixed and
matched and changed names and details on
purpose to protect the guilty but they
are all based on real life things I have
actually experienced so because we're
talking about people it's a lot easier
to talk about people that have names and
since I'm in charge for the next 40
minutes we're going to talk about this
organization which I call run the world
and is made up entirely of black women
because the concept that inclusion is
just having representatives is a fallacy
and also because audre Lorde having
power makes me really happy so run the
world is a company that makes software
for marketing automation they have a
software-as-a-service business model the
scenarios are all going to be requests
that come into their data department
from across the company and our data
analyst is Kerry Washington and Kerry is
the person that this presentation is
designed to help so here's our first
request that Kari gets Jackie
joyner-kersee and Beyonce Knowles our
sales representative and sales engineer
respectively come to our data analyst
carry with
from a potential client about why the
demonstration of the marketing
automation software and the trial that
they currently have don't match that
demo was done with the clients own data
and so that should not be the case Kerry
talks to Jackie and Beyonce and gets
details about which metrics the client
is specifically referring to what the
examples are and the representations in
each instance she comes to understand
it's an urgent issue because the sale is
on the line the client needs to trust
the run the world can you know add uh
among other things and it's the end of
the month so obviously her colleagues
really want to close the sale for their
commissions and she gives you no
additional background and clarity make
sure she is on the same page with
everyone in terms of what needs to be
done and then Kari goes to be the
problem herself because we all know you
have to be able to reproduce a bug in
order to confirm the eath question she
sees that the number is as beyonce said
it was everything checks out with the
story she has so far and she can see the
same problem with the client sees metric
a does not match metric a so Kari bank
great detective goes to try to reproduce
each version and do that calculation and
that's where she runs into her main
problem that she's going to have with
this request and that is that there are
not enough intermediary steps of the
data to reproduce senior either of the
final result numbers right we're not
even going to get into a software
versioning issue as much as it went into
a big black box so Carrie can do this
attraction and knows what the the
differences between the metrics but that
is not anything that anybody didn't
already know first of all there isn't
enough information saved anywhere on the
planet to be able to explain how metric
a in the demo differs from metric in the
trial instance so she can't answer her
friend Beyonce's question the client
doesn't know which number is true and so
can't make decisions based on facts
they're also calling into question the
validity of the entire software not just
this one metric the entire value
proposition of the software is now lost
to them and now they probably won't
make the purchase and the historical and
baseline trends are lost so this is not
a good situation that gets back to the
development team as a problem that they
need to solve and while it's clear that
they needed to save more information
they're asking themselves will which
information we can't save everything
everything so here's my answer I save
any distinctions that are needed for
reconciliation you have to think of them
as data migrations you have to keep them
and they can't all just be hard-coded in
the github repo or stored procedure in
the database or wiki page or a log file
they do have to be accessible for a
second request Kerry gets from bell
hooks our director of the support team
and marian wright edelman the company
lawyer they need to know all the times
we responded to a customer based in
Illinois regarding the guarantee the
company gives on future why so carry our
data analyst faithfully goes to get the
information out or the ticketing system
that the support team uses but she
quickly discovers that the support
ticket data is not accessible to her it
is being saved but it's being saved to a
server she doesn't have access to in a
format that none of the tools she
currently have can read so now carries
frustrated she has to spend a
significant amount of time going around
getting access to where that data is
saved and once she has access she has to
build a parser for the file format it
saved in and then process all the
historical files and then she can
actually get down to the analysis and
answering the question for bail and
Marian so marian wright edelman has not
placed and this is taking way too long
and what she hears about the problems
that carries facing she goes straight to
the head of the development team to
complain and the development team comes
together to talk amongst themselves but
their question to themselves is where
should we have saved it like we put on a
server we had access to it so you know
what's the problem the answer I would
give them is that you save things to
where the people who need access to
we're going to need it which brings me
to if your data team has access to
server a then you save data to server a
not to server are
for our third example requests ms Lord
our CEO gets an error message email
Monday morning instead of her normal
dashboard being emailed to her so Carrie
does not start off this particular week
kind of great notes it's not a way to
start a week let me tell you but the
thing is Carrie hasn't changed her code
nothing about carries a code has
actually changed in like three or four
months so what in the world happened
production how to release and made
changes to the database schema and
nobody told anybody downstream they
iterated and that's great but not only
was there not any communication there
wasn't a chance to say oh hey if you had
done it this way you could actually
either solve it so the problem or avoid
this problem there was no communication
and so the good news is that at least
there was an error message sent as
opposed you know it was an audible
failure as opposed to a silent failure
which is great because on the other side
of the office ms winfrey our chief
marketing officer has a report that says
we only have 50 new customers this month
but it's the middle of the month and the
goal for the month is 500 new customers
so based on information in her report
she starts making a huge ad by to
increase the top of her funnel so she
can make her numbers thankfully Carrie
is awesome at her job and let's
everybody that could have been affected
know what happened what was affected
what are the what's you know the
correction timeline and Miss Winfrey is
able to stop the inappropriate ad by
before any money gets committed but this
is the most egregious kind of error
because it was silent so once carries
dealt with the cleanup of the issues
that all of that created she goes to the
development team to explain and talk
through the pain that that caused and
try to make sure it never happened again
right being a good communicator
mirroring and showcasing behaviors that
she'd like to see from them and the
developers asked well what do you need
to know when we change something
and carries answer is well a that
something is changing that'd be nice
Carrie also needs to know when it's
changing why it's changing what what
necessitated this was does this
correcting for some other bug was this
just somebody's great new idea out of
the corner and they haven't talked about
it with anybody even the business side
what was the result before the change
went into effect what will be the change
after it goes into effect and she'd love
to have been asked about her concerns
and her thoughts and so she can be part
of the solution instead of part of the
problem because she obviously has a very
different visibility and perspective
into the organization than the
developers do please note that if Carrie
was in a dysfunctional organization the
DES would refuse her request to be
notified out right and she'd have to do
um resorting to other measures which is
sometimes reading every commit to the
master branch of the repo um just saying
assuming of course that she had read
access to it which can be another
problem so to go into our fifth request
run the world ink is so popular as a
marketing automation software that they
have to open an e-commerce store to sell
swag so they have logo goods and Miss
parks is our finance director and she's
preparing for an investor audit because
they're going to go into Series C
fundraising and she would like some help
calculating the value of the company
swag inventory on a 50 basis FIFO for
those of you who don't know stands for
first in first out and it's one Algrim
that's used in accounting of many
potential algorithms for this kind of
thing to handle the fact that cost of
materials change over time and it
specifically needs to know we bought 50
on this day at this price and we bought
30 on this day at this price in order to
work but here's the problem they aren't
saving history or the diffs they only
have the aggregated invoice amount they
don't know that it was 50 t-shirts and
30 stickers they only know it was like
this dollar amount for that invoice
so she doesn't have enough data to
fulfill the request there is no good way
to do this to back into the algebra
because of the level of complication of
the problem to be able to get the cost
of goods on a fifo basis for Miss parks
so carrie has an impossible task and the
question is how to prevent this in the
future and there are a couple of
different ways but for this particular
request the normal created by created at
updated at updated by fields in the
table of the inventory items itself is
not going to do it you do actually have
to have a full audit table you have to
know what changed when and what the
values are and she would actually also
add the question of what's the risk of
not knowing this information a lot of
times people do not make audit tables it
for some reason doesn't occur to
developers um but anything to do with
money should have an audit table just
throwing that out there the practical
piece of advice and then once you know
what the risk of potentially not having
the information is that makes it really
easy to justify doing the extra
development time to add the audit table
for our sixth request Oprah or chief
marketing officer and Angelica our chief
sales officer are basically in this
conversation with Harry and our COO
about what heads they're going to be
able to hire right what's their staff
count going to be next year was their
budget going to be next year and to know
that you have to know how many sales and
clients each of the sales in the
marketing team are responsible for so
you have to attribute every order and
every client to either the sales
marketing department but there's a lot
of data to integrate to get to that
answer if you want to build a marketing
funnel that's the first thing you're
going to learn is that you have to
integrate data across a lot of systems
not only at the advertising and the
website tracking and the orders you know
just to start out with right those UTM
tags or the
the g-cloud ID from an adwords campaign
being trapped in through to the order is
vital and it's probably the number one
thing that i see company is not doing so
now Carrie can't join anything together
because for instance Google Analytics
their terms of service actually say you
cannot record PII right personally
identifying information so if you
haven't tracked that UTM campaign to the
order in your database on your side you
have no way of knowing which ad or which
campaign or which copy of the ad
resulted in that sale or whether it came
from an ad at all or whether it came
from a referral from another client
hopefully you have other fields to track
that but you can you have a integration
problem really at this point so how do
you prepare for that without
over-engineering again this is like how
much can you really save so Kerry's
recommendation at this point is to store
other systems keys whenever possible
right you have to understand maintain
and force uniqueness and you might have
to actually build tools to help map
those values right sometimes values are
not exactly human readable but they need
to be so maybe your solution is
spreadsheet or maybe your solution is a
really small flask read app but foreign
keys don't just come in CSV files for
data that you purchase like if you
purchased an email list they also come
in other forms and to save them in every
place that you get them so that you can
always tie things back together because
at the end of the day everything has to
talk to each other for a seventh request
Toni Morrison is our accounts director
she is responsible for making sure
clients are happy and she comes over
complaining that invoices to clients are
being generated incorrectly instead of
charging your biggest client $500,000
the invoices for 5,000 there was a code
bug and it hit production and it
resulted in rioting inaccurate data that
flew through the system you know float
and result in an inaccurate invoice so
Carrie spends a lot of time like really
tracking down the exact place where
everything went wrong and like finding
the bug but that takes a lot a lot a lot
of time and it's time that you should be
spending building reports for the chief
marketing officer or the COO or somebody
else so the question that needs to get
asked at this point is how do you
minimize organizational pain right the
entire organization is going to suffer
if you don't get the right dollar amount
from an invoice right your accounts
receivable has to match what you're
expecting it to otherwise your budgets
just go out the window so the answer is
first obviously to stop the bleeding
right maybe you do a code rollback maybe
you you know hot fix it in production
but you have to stop the bleeding you
have to stop the inaccurate data from
being written then you have to
communicate to the company and that
especially for the accounts team since
it's affecting customers means that you
have to know the time the bug started
the time it ended on what was affected
at how like which clients were affected
what is it wasn't only clients whose
bills renewed during the time that the
bug was in effect in production or was
it some other subset of clients and then
to prevent it version control with
release tags helps you get to the actual
time stamps of when things happened
documentation documentation
documentation including of the bug and
how it was fixed and obviously then
additional tests in a test suite at the
unit level and potentially even the
integration level and then code review I
cannot stress a code review enough
because tests are really well and great
but if you don't write a test for a
problem because you don't see that that
problem could happen their test suite is
not going to save you so having more
eyes on code is better so to summarize
dear application developers
remember there's really two themes save
things and document it at communicate
and documentation is a form of
communication so really just save and
communicate sincerely the data folk and
I have talked a lot about communicating
and talking interdepartmental II and
when I do that I do have to issue a
warning which is that talking to people
outside of your organizational box that
you've been put into as a coder isn't
that without risk I personally have been
highly criticized for not staying in the
organizational box even when it means
that I'm being proactive in getting to
the root of the problem and moving the
needle of the organizational bottom line
in a positive direction since I've been
in that position let me give you a bonus
piece of knowledge that i didn't have
until recently that should help you out
and that is this lovely word go in the
devops dictionary in case you can't read
it a goat is a slang for a person who is
very curious and tends not to respect
organizational boundaries it is named
after the goats who tend to find ways
out of their pens and an organizational
context goats can have a powerful effect
as their initiative and
interdisciplinary nature makes them
ideal candidates for grassroot DevOps
programs in other words people who can
talk to people can solve problems and
are actually very helpful and with that
note I will take us into QA
so how much of this is is kind of like
culture communication organizational and
how much of it can be solved by to leap
and who owns that process is that the
stakeholders that people didn't need
these answers like should they be
communicating or should the Japs realize
this as they're working in my try to be
thinking well first of all I would argue
that data people have to be at the
stakeholder table at the beginning
before any specs get decided on and then
I would say as much as I am a geek and
dev and I want to have tools to solve
everything for me that is not really the
root of the issue I mean you could build
a tool to make the communication happen
or you could just go stand up and talk
to somebody so as much as as much as the
coder and me just wants to sit in code
it really really really is about talking
to people
um so I will repeat the question how as
a dev should you be communicating that
it changes coming and what it's doing in
terms of medium and and so it sometimes
I'm times depends on the organizational
structure for communication right if
everybody always emails everything then
it should be an email if the wiki is
kept really up to date and that is the
source of truth for everyone then it
should be in the wiki and maybe a
notification in slack and or an email
right it's a it's making sure that
people know about it and that can be in
different ways but I would say that the
communication needs to be very clear and
concise and include who to follow up
with if you have other questions almost
always I will have other questions for
you and it's generally about really
silly cases that not everybody needs to
know about or care about it doesn't need
to be an email chain I just and an
almost always the person that I need to
be talking to is not the product manager
it is the dev yeah yeah
so depending on your organization
depends on whether the data team has the
ownership of the etl pipelines or the
devs do i would say at a minimum the
access and the connection to be able to
get it into the data warehouse needs to
be there but obviously the details
change / organization the the main thing
is to know that it is going to have to
get to that one central data warehouse
in order to be useful in the long run
and so like building something in a
completely separated like entirely
different like server like if everything
you're doing is an AWS and all of a
sudden you go build something on Google
App Engine you should probably be asking
yourself while you're doing that Amy so
the question is and I've been talking
about developers talking to data people
is there a parallel process for talking
to stakeholders and I would go back to
what I said a couple minutes ago about
the data person should be a stakeholder
because data is that important data if
we really want to be data-driven
decision-making organizations we have to
put data people at the front of the line
and at the table and that means that
they are stakeholder in the first place
yeah it is a leading question how do you
feel about meetings miss like the
standing way to do versus getting out in
front of like a chicken attack so the
question is about how do meetings play
into the communication is a meeting once
a week the answer it's generally not
for many reasons but one is that a lot
of things especially when you're doing
agile development cannot wait until that
one day we can you have a meeting and so
I think it's a lot about building
relationships and I also think it's a
lot about not everybody is great at
being a speaker and not everybody is
great being a listener some people
absorb information better by reading and
we have different learning types so
almost always there should be something
written whether that is meeting notes or
an email or a slack message or a wiki
page especially for the super uber
important things when something is in
writing you can refer back to it and you
can say three months from now like no my
understanding was this because this is
what got written and everybody had a
chance to say if that was actually
accurate and reflective of such and such
and nobody said anything so I assumed
this because that's what was written and
it helps a lot when um people are like
oh but I told you I'm like but no you
didn't
let's take a second